rmt general secretary mick lynch
listening to the transport secretary
joining us now hello to you mr lynch
great to see you thanks for joining us
on the program he was talking about you
what are you going to say in response
oh i didn't hear all of it he seemed to
be saying that railway workers have
received 160 000 pound in subsidy what
he really means is that he's given the
private sector operators that money and
last year
they removed 500 million pounds from
this industry in profit so it's it's his
construction of the way that the railway
industry that is
is shaped at the moment is causing these
problems and he's responsible for this
dispute
in the sense that he has a veto on what
the train operating companies can offer
us it's written into their contracts
that he's directly responsible for
industrial relations and he can dictate
what the terms are and the fact is
they've made no offer on pay towards our
members what they've offered us is mass
redundancies
uh recon recontracting our members on
inferior terms and conditions massive
changes to their work-life balance and
cuts in network rail to the to the
safety regime of up to 50
of the inspection so
he's caused this problem but he's got to
facilitate a way out of it and he could
do that today and if he wants to to
facilitate
a negotiated set i mean i'm very happy
to deal with him but what he won't do is
contact me
or any of my officers or any of the
people responsible for this negotiation
and create a way forward
and the reason he won't is beca because
he says that you're militant that you're
extreme left and he went on to say that
you're not normal because there have
been
160 different
disputes and there is some sort of
dispute or
balancing for a dispute every single day
well it's ironic to be called not normal
by the conservative party who are taking
themselves into the realms of the
extreme right at the moment as we've
seen
in this contest they're saying that
paying tax isn't normal and having free
trade unions with the ability to take
industrial action
isn't normal the people behind me are
ordinary men and women in this country
they work hard to deliver the railway
service and what they don't want to do
is see their wages diluted their terms
and conditions diluted and their
contracts of employment ripped up
so i'm not a militant i'm not even a
member of a political party and i
haven't been for 30 years so
the idea that we're running some
ideological campaign is nonsense frankly
what we want to do is get a settlement
so straightforward industrial dispute on
jobs pay and conditions and we can be we
could do that if grant chaps would allow
the companies to negotiate freely and he
hadn't cut two billion pounds from the
funding of the national railway and two
billion pounds from the london
underground in the last few weeks
is it right is it true what he said that
there have been 160 different
disputes or threats of disputes and
there is some threat every single day
[Applause]
well we deal we deal with over 500
companies in the transport sector
ranging from bus
to um
sorry
fire engine ranging from bus to the
ferries
and lots of other uh entities that we
deal with so we will always defend our
members
not all of those disputes run into
industrial action industrial action is
quite rare on the railway and in the
transport sector
so we we will always work with our
employees to try and get a settlement
to any of the disputes that we're
involved in and what we've got here is a
protracted dispute because of the stance
of this government and because of grant
shap's attitude
and is his approach towards industrial
relations so if
these companies were allowed to act as
all the other companies are yeah we
would get a settlement to this dispute
is it right that he says that two vans
when have to go to every job as opposed
to
even one van being needed but you double
up on everything
no that's a lot of nonsense he doesn't
know what he's talking about we are
talking to network rail about the
deployment of staff every day of the
week there's never been an occasion
where our members refuse to get in a van
with other people was rubbish
okay just to clarify he made the point
and i'm glad you've clarified it for us
um four percent is what you've been
offered uh with a possible four percent
next year as well depending on on uh
changes um to working practices um has
that often been made to your members or
did you reject it
um before uh even offering it to them
well we haven't been offered a
straightforward pay deal what we've been
offered is a set of conditions we've got
to accept nearly 2 000 redundancies
we've got to set accept cuts in the
maintenance regime of up to 50
we've got to accept massive changes to
our members working conditions and the
offer that they've made is conditional
on all of those things and it's a four
percent offer that covers last year and
this year and next year's offer
would take it to a three-year deal
inflation today the retail price index
is 11.8 so it doesn't go anywhere near
resolving the cost of living crisis but
what we want to do first is work out
what the conditions are get a guarantee
of no compulsory redundancies and then
we can work on the pay but people are
being impoverished in this country by
below inflation pay deals and this is
yet another below inflation paid deal
what we do with those offers is consult
our members in mass meetings and we have
done that and they have overwhelmingly
given us the answer that they reject
that offer
and those latest conditions have they
been put to your members
yeah we explained all of the offers to
our members and we brought them and they
said no thanks we want to go on strike
again because the reason i'm pushing you
on this mr lynch is because apparently
um that isn't the case and your members
have not been given the opportunity to
uh offer their opinion on the latest
offer from network rail that again is is
incorrect yeah
they've been offered the opportunity to
offer their opinion through their
representatives the same way that mps
represent their constituents we have a
network of representatives and the offer
is obviously unacceptable because if you
look behind me
our people are out on strike in massive
numbers we've got 43 000 people in this
strike when we started we had just over
40 000 people
railway workers are joining this dispute
so they because they want to go on
strike in response to what the
government is offering
the membership in this dispute has grown
by two and a half thousand since the
last strike action so the the support
for this dispute is growing by people
joining the rmt
in response to what they see as these
paltry offers and the offer of
impoverishment going forward okay eddie
dempsey rmt union negotiator i'm sure
you know him um apparently he's said by
industry sources to have um said we can
see a way through it and are prepared to
postpone the strikes
um is that true
that's completely untrue we can see a
way through it we can see the way to a
negotiated settlement but we've never
said to anyone that we're prepared to
postpone the strikes we take the offers
back to our executive committee we talk
to our members we examine the offer
against
what the dispute is about and the offers
so far have not matched what we need to
settle the dispute and i also say kay
that we've not had an offer from the
train operating companies half the
people in dispute work for train
operators and there is no pay offer
whatsoever there is no job security
offer and all that they've proposed is
they shut every ticket office they put
all of our members on new contracts of
employment just like the p o dispute and
fire and rehire and none of that is
acceptable to anyone in our union
uh it looks like uh well certainly as we
speak liz tross is the favorite to be
the next prime minister um she says
she's had enough the union barons i
think she means you
i've got too much power and that power
will be removed with a change in the law
what would you say in response to her
well i'm not a union baron i'm an
elected officer of this union and the
people behind me elect me and they can
get rid of me if they want to
through the election process
we haven't got too much power the
problem in this country is that trade
unions don't have enough power that's
why so many people are suffering poor
wages that's why there's such an
imbalance in the workplace and it's a
shame that the tory party is descending
into an ultra white right clique at the
moment and liz trust is seeking to take
away human rights and the ability of the
democratic right of people to express
themselves through their trade unions
and industrial action which is one of
the pillars of our democracy it's only
repressive regimes that stop people
going on strike and stop them expressing
themselves and stop them rebalancing
the power in the workplace through that
you're a busy monster i'm going to have
to let you go one final question before
i do that you say you haven't got enough
power how much what more power do you
want
well what we want is the ability to
express ourselves as free trade unions
so that we don't have these oppressive
anti-trade union laws we don't have the
threats of millions of pounds of fines
against trade unions and we don't want
to go back to the 70s where one of the
previous
tory governments put trade unionists in
prison for taking industrial action and
if that's the path we're going down
we're going to live in a very repressive
society we want to act freely as
democratic people with people that live
in a liberal society